[Music]
thank you
are you happy in your work well that's
certainly not a question I get asked
very regularly but in the Civil Service
Naval gazing is an annual routine
sketchwriter Quentin lets at the Times
writes for this week's magazine that
feedback forms and people surveys have
turned to blob into a bureaucratic
machine incapable of getting work done
but is he right he's with me now to
discuss
now Quentin you write in this week's
magazine about the Civil Service people
survey tell us what inspired you to
write about this well there was a select
committee in which the uh the Chief
Operating Officer of the Civil Service
Alex Chisholm I almost called him sir
Alex was giving evidence about this
thing along with two other top mandarins
this is the people survey where they
basically the Civil Service goes to 350
000 civil servants and does to them what
happens in cheap restaurants when
someone comes along and says everything
all right with your meal and uh this is
the Civil Service saying to its
employees is there anything you want to
complain about and guess what they they
do they do want to complain about and
the main thing they want to complain
about is pay yeah so they say
um we we think we're being worked too
hard and we're not being paid enough
and uh therefore there is now then
evidence for uh for pay Rises It's a
Wonderful Circle
you've been covering Westminster now for
about 30 odd years how was this sorry to
remind you how was the quality of
Mandarin of Humphrey changed in that
time well it was not
not subpar
um the civil servants of old tended not
to be seen very much and didn't do
nearly as many select committees
and therefore we had an ideal they were
these great figures in Elysium who were
able
and now that we can see them we realize
that anything but able and they're
frightful wafflers and Chisholm uh has
he has a wonderful voice very deep voice
downside he went to inside went to
Oxford he's all the business but he
talks seamless balls uh if we can say
that and um really it just comes out of
him
um like a a long stream of sausage and
uh they was with with two other people
doing the same next to him must be quite
a tough experience for you
these these select committees become
like this but going back to your
question about the civil servants I
think
I suspect that they have always probably
been not as good as we we hoped or we
imagined
but it's quite good if you're not very
good
to keep quiet about it and not to be
seen on Parade so my advice to mandarins
is you know if you're asked to do a
select committee say no
and you've had a bit of a run-in with
Alexis when you're writing this week I
had a run-in with his meter
um uh I wrote about him before in the
times and I took the rise slightly and
uh um mother Chisholm wrote In from I
think Hampshire
um a stealing missive arrived from a
handwritten in ink and uh almost
levitating off the desk she was so angry
with me and I loved it I thought she was
terrific and she put me for me in my
Pace she's obviously um you know a
proper old dragon and uh and I I've
fallen in love with Mr Chisholm now but
um you know her son is still worthy of a
certain amount of satire and what do you
think about each sort of talk about the
Civil Service being a sort of conspiracy
about side of a blob do you think that
they're capable enough to mount a coup
against the government well they are
quite good the one thing they're good at
the civil service is taking tax out of
our pockets it's funny when it comes to
actually doing stuff that looks after
them
um or giving them the money to pay pay
themselves they are quite good and so
they do this people survey
um 350 000 people I think there's
something like 17 000 business units in
the Civil Service get this and uh across
100 departments and uh it's quite a big
operation it obviously has a team of
people who are needed I must say
listening to that select committee do
you remember the bird and Fortune yeah
it was very like that where the the
self-justifications and about how
important it was about how much hard
work it was
and not only do they have the survey
they also have surveys of the survey and
they have benchmarking and they have
best practice and uh there's also an
international element where the oecd is
involved and so that presumably
necessitates foreign fact-finding trips
uh over weekends in glorious places like
Strasbourg and uh sunnier climbs but uh
the the I don't know I mean it's a rude
question James have you ever mined your
belly button for fluff
and it you know you can find things
a Moorish activity you look down you say
well that's interesting you find a bit
of old lunch and the more you do it the
more you want to do it and it becomes a
terrible time waster and this is
basically what this people survey is
it's a terrible time wasting belly
button fluff
um mining operation and I think it was
Peter Hennessy and calling the phrase
that is often in Whitehall it's not so
much about evidence-based policy making
as policy-based evidence-making where
you get into this kind of endless cycle
of stuff Peter would have loved this but
of course Peter was the uh tutor of
Simon case who is the head of the Civil
Service and why on Earth at a time when
our tax rates are shooting up when our
national debt is shooting up what we're
doing wasting time and money on this I
don't know we and it was not disclosed
how much this cost but one dreads to
think and um they were asked how often
people looked at these dashboards they
have dashboards of course for the um
this this people survey and 17 000 civil
servants a day look at this thing but
you know this survey that wouldn't you
like to be asked how you're feeling it
look
not wildly I've never been in almost
here as you mentioned of being a hack
I've never been asked I don't think I
can't remember ever being asked are you
happy
and um what a waste of time let's just
get on with the job and my final
question Quentin I mean you've been
covering Whitehall for 30 or two years
or so I'm sure there'll be some aspiring
mandarins watching this at home young
civil servants what kind of tips would
you give them on in a game if you're
going to be in a select commission you
can't get out of it what are the best
ways to waffle and prevaricate that
you've seen from your many years
watching these things you've got very
short answers very short answer yes or
no and then the MP hasn't had time to
think up next it's the same at Prime
Minister's questions brevity is all
brevity is completely confounding uh it
throughs them and also that way you
you'll get out of it quicker because
they'll run out of questions well there
we are for those watching at home thank
you Clinton
thank you
[Music]
foreign